do you remember the day that you landed
in LA yes I was an interesting flight
because I missed it and I had a delay I
was alone and I only had what three bags
with me I had sold my car like days
prior so I was just on public transit
system just to make it out here and then
I got a late flight finally came here
real late and the guy that picked me up
was a you know my friend my roommate he
picked me up and she was like he came to
the day before because he thought my
flight was supposed to be there so that
was interesting and my experience in LA
that first day was it's pretty
interesting cuz we got almost got into a
fight at the diner so I was yeah my
first experience here was pretty rough
no I wasn't used to how certain cultures
were out here and back home if you get
stared at by somebody for more than 7
seconds you ask questions like hey do we
know each other and the person didn't I
guess wrecked he was you know I guess he
was Armenian he just looked at me he
started smoking a cigarette and almost
gotten a fight the first day here so I
was like yeah la is pretty rough so far
but it you know turned out pretty well
so now how do you deal with that when
people I kind of do this a are you down
for whatever reason look the other way
don't care I have to dwell on it just
keep it moving
so when you came out here seven years
ago yeah - now are your impressions of
LA better or worse
say uh you come here you know with glass
bottles you're here you see the glitz
the glamour and you start to learn
that's it's a tough town
you have to deal with rejection almost
all the time the people here are
friendly but you know it's kind of you
just have to learn how to play the game
that's the one thing I learned it's it's
it's not it's it's it's a tough town
what's the game oh man learning to try
to push yourself ahead when everybody
else is trying to do the same thing
either with evil intention or good
intention it's just trying to keep a
team or a foundation of people around
you that has a good soul and trying to
succeed at the same time so I guess
that's pretty much on the game is that's
my opinion that's what I think it is now
what do you use for your gut check when
you can tell maybe someone's intentions
aren't well thankfully I have like one
of those radars were you kind of like ah
okay
you're you're you're you're not trying
to help me out or we're not trying to on
the same level you're here for something
totally different
thankfully I've been there but then
again there's some people who are very
good actors that are on the outside
trying to make stuff happen and you say
okay you just here to try to take money
out of me or something it's it's a tough
town man tough town what got you into
acting was it before you came out here
you decided oh no uh when I was younger
I was forced into plays when I was
around four or five years old my uncle
he's an author so he would write they
know playwrights but they would be in
French so it was tough for me because
growing up out here
French is like you know a second
language in my family so he forced us to
do that so it got me into the plays and
then I started doing like she
films here and there back home then I
stopped for a while because I got into
you know sports and stuff and you know
my friends were inside thinking that's
all you gonna do what your friends do
then when I went to college I started
going back to theater again and falling
in love with it again gonna head as soon
as I left college had to come out here
so once you came out here seven years
ago what were some of the first steps
that you did to get yourself intact well
the first steps you do you're told to do
is get your head shots try to meet a
manager or some source that help you out
go to central casting and sancho casting
helps you a lot because it shows you the
ins and outs are just like TV and film
and you see oh okay this is what they do
everybody says it's anything I could do
that but just to get to that certain
level is the way you gotta learn it's
you know you come yeah central casting
that was that was that was the best
learning experience and then you know
you jump in Tasmania's classes as you
can from Meisner to whatever technique
hurt you know helps you a lot of people
do the improv UCB or The Groundlings but
yeah I try to take as much as I can from
every school I learned
you